يعني كان
لافت هذا الحديث الذي نقلته وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه لمسؤول عسكري اسرائيلي ان حركه
حماس تعيد ترتيب او اضاعها العسكريه
وتاهيل اي كوادرها من جديد في شمال قطاع
غزه حيث اصل العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
البريه والتي تركز فيها ايضا العمل
العسكري من الجو ماذا يعني ذلك
حسن هي خلال الحرب او
خلال الدخول الى غزه او غزو غزه دائما
هناك عمليه تاقلم مع الواقع الميداني يعني
انت يكون لديك خطه معينه عسكريه لسيناريو
محتمل ولكن دائما الواقع الارض يعكس شيء
لم يكن في الحسبان اليوم قدره المقاومه
على التاقلم هي اسرع يعني دائره القرار
لدى المقاومه هي اسرع لانها تقاتل بطريقه
مختلفه عن جيش معقد في شمال القطاع عندما
يتقدم الجيش الاسرائيلي تبدا الكمائن
وتبدا العبوات ويبدا استهداف الاليات ولكن
عندما يتراجع تبدا عمليه الاغاره هذا ما
حصل او ما يحصل في شمال القطاع هناك خسائر
بالطبع هناك خسائر لدى المقاومه ولكن
عمليه التاهيل هذا يعني ان المقاومه اصبح
لديها مساحه مساحه عمليات اكثر راحه اكثر
وبالتالي قادره على اعاده التنظيم
والترتيب للمرحله القادمه والتي يعتبرها
الاسرائيل انها المرحله الثالثه يعني
اعاده التاهيل هذه اي تحصل طبعا وفقا لما
قالته ئر اذا اعاده التاهيل تحصل في حين
اننا نشاهد ايه عمليات تقوم بها كتائب
القسام واستهداف وكمائن في نفس الوقت وفي
نفس المنطقه ايضا في شمال لقطاع غزه على
ما يدل ذلك بالنسبه ل بنيه ايه المقاومه
وبنيه حركه حماس التي اي وضعت اسرائيل
هدفا وهو القضاء عليها في
البدايه ايه حركه حماس انا لا اقول
التاهيل لانه في هذه المرحله التاهيل هو
اعاده التدريب والتجهيز وما شابه اليوم
المقاومه ليس لديها وقت للتاهيل هي تاخذ
من القيادات الموجوده لان تركيبه حماس
العسكريه مختلفه عن الجيوش التقليديه
وتضعها في مكان ما يعني اذا قتل او استشهد
قائد ميداني عملاني يتم التعيين من هو
بعده او او من هو مؤهل ولكن الشيء الفريد
في هذا الموضوع انك اذا اردت على سبيل
المثال ان تؤهل او تعيد بناء وتنظيم كتيبه
جباليا انما تاخذ من المنطقه التي تتواجد
فيها كتيبه قائد بديل لماذا لانه يعي
المكان ويعي الزمان ولكن اليوم كما قلت
قدره المقاومه على التاقلم هي اسرع
والقتال يعني حتى لو انخفضت قدره قتال
كتيبه معينه التي تقدر ب 1000 مقاتل من
حماس حتى لو انخفضت الى ال 250 يعني
75% خساره هي قادره على القتال يكفي تي بي
جي يكفي ياسين
ويكفي لغم معين او شواظ ل الا يدل ذلك على
ان ال القياده العليا ما تزال قادره
ومسيطره في نفس الوقت وهي على تواصل مع كل
القطاعات الاخرى الموجوده في في تلك
المنطقه تحديدا في الشمال شمال
القطاع بالطبع هناك تركيبه هناك المقاتل
هناك امر الف الفصيله هناك امر السريه
هناك قائد الكتيبه وهو من ضمن منظومه حتى
التعاون بين التنظيمات المختلفه داخل
القطاع هناك قياده مشتركه وقياده وسيطره
بالطبع لماذا لانه اي قرار يؤخذ على صعيد
القياده الكبرى هو نتيجه الت تقيييم الوضع
الميداني وبالتالي حتى قرار اطلاق
الصواريخ على غلاف غزه بعدد 50 صاروخ هذا
امر يتطلب قرار من القياده ولكن دائما حسن
التنفيذ العملاني يدل على قدره المقاومه
انها لا تزال قادره وهذا ما نشرته على
سبيل المثال جريده نيويورك تايمز حول فاق
700 كم وحول الصواريخ وهؤلاء يعني هذين
البعدين هما الهاجس الاكبر لجيش الاحتلال
طيب لنعود الى المشاهد التي
بثت على الشاشه قبل قليل هي مشاهد لكمائن
والتحام ا كانان في حيي الزيتون والدرج او
التفاح والدرج وايضا في شمال قطاع
غزه ما الذي لفتك في هذه المشاهد ربما هي
مكرره في اماكن معينه ولكن بقي ان لديها
دلالات خاصه
ايضا ايه هذه
الانفاق تعطي انسيابيه وتعطي حركيه وتعطي
ما يسمى بالامن العملاني يعني امن الوحدات
التي تنفذ هي قادره على الوصول الى الهدف
الذي يعتبر ثابت ومهم جدا ان تضرب هذا
الهدف تدمر هذا الهدف وتختفي بسرعه وهذا
الامر يخلق قلق كبير جدا يعني نحن لدينا
او لدى المقاومه عالم مختلف تحت الارض
يقدر ب 700 م 5800 فتحه لهذه الانفاق لكل
نفق منها مهمه معينه النفق تقريبا تحت
الارض بما بعمق معين الهدف الاكبر او
النفق الاغمق اعمق او النفق الاعمق وهذه
لكل منها اليه معينه هذه جهازيه حسن تعمل
من ضمن هدف معين والانفاق هي تدخل في
العقيده العسكريه الامنيه للمقاومه